Wagner restera à barmouth dans un
message audio publié ce dimanche
evegaini Prigogine renonce à retirer ses
troupes de la vie ukrainienne selon lui
le Kremlin a accédé à ses demandes
pourquoi
on nous a promis autant de munitions et
d'armement que nécessaire pour continuer
nos opérations on nous a promis que tout
ce dont on avait besoin pour empêcher
l'ennemi de nous couper
l'approvisionnement sera déployée sur
les flancs
vendredi dans une vidéo le chef du
groupe paramilitaire avait violemment
interpellé le ministre de la Défense
faute de munitions supplémentaires il
menaçait de laisser ses positions à
barmut au leader tchétchène Ramzan
Kadirov ce dernier à la tête d'un
bataillon de plusieurs milliers d'hommes
avaient répondu favorablement à la
demande de prix gaugine
j'ai écrit une lettre recommandant en
chef suprême Vladimir Poutine pour lui
dire que nous sommes prêts à prendre bar
mout
très heureux de reprendre les
territoires restants
nommé en général pour coordonner les
efforts de Wagner et de l'armée
régulière depuis l'été dernier la Russie
tente de conquérir barmut au prix de
lourdes pertes humaines et matériel pour
les deux côtés selon Kiev Wagner
pourrait tenter de s'emparer de la
totalité de la ville d'ici mardi un
moyen pour le Kremlin de célébrer le 9
mai jour anniversaire de la victoire de
l'URSS sur l'Allemagne Nazie en 1945